I'm writing you this later no text no
email something real something you feel
I'm writing you this later
R B singer B Smith has died he was 28
years old I want to make you know music
for pretty much everyone I wanted you to
be able to you know work out to my music
you know clean up your house or you know
just if you want to you know put the top
back or something go to the beach
revealed the new of B's death in an
emotional video explaining the musician
born Brandon Smith died from respiratory
failure after a long battle with
pulmonary fibrosis
today my brother
passed away
um early earlier this morning to be
exact he passed away and um with a fight
that he was having with the lung
condition
um
it's very tough for me to make this
video because I thought I never would
have to make something like this
be success in music begin online I got
my start basically on YouTube what I was
doing was just doing cover videos every
week and that's that's pretty much I was
I was able to build a pretty big fan
base you know doing that and that was
about like two years ago Motown records
caught wind of his talent and they
signed him in 2012. right off the bat
the singer collaborated with two chains
for his debut single Lego which peaked
at number 12 on Billboard's Hot r b
songs chart what goes around come back
around now I'm back in town
[Music]
but it was B song twerkaholic in 2014
that instantly became a fan favorite
oh yeah
oh yeah it's really based off you know
how hard you were how hard you work and
how bad you really wanted so I'll just
say to really stay focused you know stay
humble and really stay at it and just
last month the singer dropped
twerkaholic part two same
[Music]
brother shared that while he was in the
ICU fans brought him a lot of Smiles by
creating social media challenges for the
song all those new tick tock
Tick Tock reels made him
[Music]
may have have a smoother process you
know it gave all the love and lightness
you guys were sending him I'm going to
actually see my fans you know being able
to you know actually touch them and they
can actually you know fail me so I mean
it's it's pretty great you know it's a
lot more you know
um
uh experiences and you know being on
stage and all that stuff so I love it
all I love it all